meanwhile a Ukrainian officials saying
Russia has launched massive missile
strikes against the country causing Now
power and water outages people in the
capital cave say they heard at least a
five explosions and this as Ukraine
reports of fierce fighting in the
country's East in his nightly addressed
president zelanski said Ukrainian troops
had repelled the latest Russian attacks
in the Danette region fighting there has
centered on these strategically
important town of bakmut which Russian
forces have been trying to capture for
weeks
well I discussed the attack with kiev's
mayor Vitali Klitschko
uh everyone it's uh today in this
massive uh attack his attack to our
hometown it's uh settings to our
um uh military forces they shoot down
actually uh majority of Records the
biggest part of reckons was shut down
and bought a couple of Records
destroyed our infrastructure
objects and the effect was horrible 350
000 apartments in our hometown was
without electricity and and 80 of uh
city of capital today Monique was
without the water
the whole day the whole day the
engineers working in right now we
starting to give the bag the electricity
and
also water but it's my personal opinion
is the Russians forces not successful
right now on the front line and
they they may change the tactics right
now
to make a pressure to civilian people to
destroy the life of normal people to
want to freezing whole population in the
city not just in City Gear it's another
city it's also was in under a wrecked
attack I just understood so as winter
approaches then does it look like Russia
is going to achieve these aims that you
ascribe to it to demoralize our people
in your city as winter approaches
yeah it's uh my personal opinion they
try to demoralize the people to bring
the people the impression make
depression with people uh especially
right now actually it's pretty cold uh
outside and uh instead them the people
getting angry and we understand uh it's
unhuman rights it's uh it's like the
Russians do it as terrorists and the
people very angry about that and we're
ready to defend our houses our citizen
our homeland and uh actually the the
expectation of Russians doesn't work we
have a different type right and and as
you repair those Power and Water
Supplies though you talk about people
there being angry as you go about these
repairs you do so knowing that they are
likely to be targeted again
uh definitely definitely Russians they
change it that is the the latest success
in Frontline and right now they try to
destroy critical infrastructure water
electricity uh the normal life of
citizens of civilians and that's why I
told the the Russians uh
[Music]
explain the fake news they lying about
the Special Operation it's a war against
military they fighting against civilians
they need territory they need property
they need country without citizens they
need Ukraine without ukrainians it's my
personal opinion okay now as the rest of
Europe heads into a winter of record
inflation and massive power bills you
talk about your people being angry do
you worry that political support in the
rest of Europe will waver as politicians
worry about their own uh voters their
anger about these massive bills and
inflation
uh first of all I want to say thank you
very much for every uh everyone in
Europe who support Ukraine we need your
help it's very important for us critical
important for Ukraine right now to to
receive the political economical support
uh they go in there and help and we
understand it's it's very very important
for us and we never forget you have you
have and please stay with Ukraine it's
very important for us because we fight
against defending not just our homes and
our uh country we defending every one of
you in Europe we're fighting for the
same democratic values for human rights
for oppressive freedom for Democratic
violence and we defending you because
I'm more than sure the Russians go so
far as far we allowed to go